we saw in the last video that if we
defined enthalpy h
as being equal to the internal energy of
a system plus the pressure of the system
times the volume of the system and this
is an almost arbitrary definition but we
know that this is a valid state variable
that no matter what you do in terms of
how you get there you're always going to
have the same value because it's the sum
and product of other valid state
variables but this by itself isn't that
useful or that intuitive but we saw in
the last video that if you assume
constant pressure and that's a big
assumption but it's not a unreasonable
assumption for most chemical reactions
because most chemical reactions you know
we're sitting at the beach with our
beakers and they're exposed to just
standard
temperature and pressure or at least
some pressure that's it's not
changing as the reaction occurs if we
assume constant pressure we saw that the
change in enthalpy
that the change in enthalpy
becomes the heat added to the system at
that constant pressure that p there is
just to show you that hey this is just
when we're just when this is this is
assuming that we're dealing with heat
being added at a constant pressure fair
enough so how can we how can we use
these concepts in any useful way
let's say that i had some carbon in its
elemental form as graphite and i add to
that i have to have a mole of carbon and
i added that two moles of hydrogen in
its elemental form
it's going to be a gas it's going to be
as a molecule right if i just have a
bunch of heart a bunch of hydrogen in
its gaseous state let's say in a balloon
i'm not going to have individual atoms
of hydrogen they're going to bond and
form these diatomic molecules
and if i react them
i'm going to produce
a mole of methane a mole of methane
ch4 but that's not all i'm going to
produce i'm also going to produce some
heat
i'm going to produce
i'm going to produce 74
kilojoules of heat
plus 74
kilojoules of heat when i produce
when i produce that one mole like i'll
do a lowercase k for the kilo when i
when i produce that one mole of methane
so what's happening here
so first of all how much heat is being
added to the system and let's assume
that this heat just gets released from
the system that this isn't an adiabatic
process i haven't insulated the system
from anything that this just gets
released it just goes away it gets
released
so my question is
how much you know i started off with
this container i guess we could call it
that's at a standard you know it's at a
fixed pressure and maybe i had a bunch
of uh well i want to do the carbon i'll
do it in gray
i have a bunch of solid carbon laying
around maybe some type of dust and then
i have some hydrogen molecular hydrogen
gas each of those dots there's actually
two hydrogen atoms and i don't know
maybe i shake it up or something to make
them react and then i get a bunch of
methane
and then i get a bunch of methane
i get a bunch of methane gas
i'll do that in green
so now i just have a bunch of methane
gas and i released 74 kilojoules
i released 74 kilojoules
so how much heat was added to the system
well we released heat from the system we
released 74 kilojoules so the heat added
to the system
the heat added to the system was minus
74 kilojoules minus 74 right if i asked
you the heat released then i would have
said 74 but remember we care about the
heat added to the system is 74
kilojoules and i just showed you that
that's the exact same thing as the
change in enthalpy
as the change in enthalpy
so how can we think about this what is
the enthalpy of this system
relative to this system what's going to
be lower right
because if you take enthalpy so the
change in enthalpy is the enthalpy
of your final system minus the enthalpy
of your initial system
and we got a negative number we got
minus 74 kilojoules so this has to be
lower than this by 74 kilojoules
so h this enthalpy right here is less
than
this enthalpy right here so if we were
actually drawn on a diagram
if i actually draw the
reaction let's say that this is just i
know this is just time or something this
is as the reaction proceeds that axis
and on the y-axis i'll draw
enthalpy
so the reaction starts off at your
initial enthalpy
h i and that's this state right here so
you start there i'll do it in the the
yellow of that container
so this yellow i'll do it right there
you start there
and then i don't know you shake it up or
i'm not going to go into the activation
energy so it might have a little hump in
all that but who knows but then we end
up at our final enthalpy
we have this final enthalpy right here
after the reaction has occurred that's
this state right here this is h final
so you can see you've had this drop-off
in enthalpy and what's interesting here
is is that not so much what the absolute
value of this enthalpy is here or the
absolute value of this enthalpy here is
but now that we have enthalpy we can
kind of have a a framework for thinking
about how much heat energy is in this
system relative to this system and given
that there's less heat energy in this
system than that energy system we must
have released energy and you know to
some degree i told you that from the
beginning right i told you that energy
is released and the word for this we use
is exothermic
exothermic
now if you want to go the other way
let's say we wanted to go from methane
and go back to its br you have to add
heat into the reaction you would have to
if you wanted to go
backwards through this reaction go
upwards you would actually have you
would have to add that heat content to
get that positive delta h and then you
would have an endothermic reaction so if
a reaction releases energy exothermic if
a reaction
needs energy to occur it's endothermic
now you might be asking sal where did
that energy come from so i started at
this enthalpy here and enthalpy has this
weird definition right here and then end
up at that other enthalpy here and as
you see enthalpy you know the pressure
we're assuming is constant let's say the
volume isn't changing much in this
situation or maybe doesn't change at all
so most of the change is going to come
from the change in internal energy right
there's some higher internal energy here
and some higher internal and some lower
internal energy here that's causing the
main drop in enthalpy and that change in
internal energy is really a a conversion
from some potential energy up here into
the heat that's released so there was
some heat that was released 74
kilojoules and so our internal energy
dropped and what all of this does is it
gives us a framework so that if we know
how much heat it takes to form or not
form certain products then we can kind
of predict how much heat will either be
released or how much heat will be
absorbed by different reactions and so
here i'm going to touch on another
notion the notion of
heat of formation or sometimes it's
change in enthalpy of formation so the
way they talk about it is the change in
enthalpy
of formation and it's normally given at
some standard temperature and pressure
so you put a little usually it's a not
sometimes it's just a circle in there
and what that is is how much what is the
change in enthalpy
to get to that to get to some molecule
from its elemental form so for example
if we want it for
for methane if we have methane there and
we want to figure out its
if we want to figure out its
heat of formation
we say look if we form methane from its
elemental forms what is the delta h of
that reaction well we just learned what
the delta h of that reaction was it was
minus 74
kilojoules which means that if you form
methane from its elemental
i guess building blocks you're going to
release 74 kilojoules of energy that
this is an exothermic reaction
exothermic reaction
because you've released heat you also
have this you can kind of say that the
methane is in a lower energy state or it
has lower potential energy than these
guys did and because it has lower
potential energy it's more stable
i mean one way to think of it is you
know if you have a guy you know you have
a mountain here and then it's down here
and you have a ball
you have a ball and this isn't you know
a complete direct analogy but the
analogy to potential energy is look when
you're down at a lower potential energy
state
you tend to be more stable and so in in
the everyday world if you have a bunch
of methane sitting around the fact that
it has a negative
heat of reaction or heat of sorry a
negative heat of formation or a negative
i should say standard heat of formation
because i have that knot here or or a
negative standard change in enthalpy of
formation those are all the same things
tells me that methane is stable relative
to its constituent compounds and
actually you can look these things up
you'll never have to memorize them but
it's good to know what they are and i
copied all of this stuff
actually let me
get the actual
get the actual tables from wikipedia
down here i copied all these directly
from wikipedia these give you that the
standard heat of formation of a bunch of
things and if you look if you look down
here
for let's see if they have methane right
there this is what we were dealing with
they're telling us essentially the delta
h of that of the reaction that forms
methane they're telling us
they're telling us that you know this
point table right there tells us that if
we start off with
some carbon in a solid state plus two
moles of hydrogen in the gaseous state
and we form one mole of methane
that if you take the enthalpy here
minus the enthalpy here so the change in
enthalpy for this reaction
at a at standard temperature and
pressure is going to be equal to minus
74 kilojoules per mole and this is all
given per mole so if you have a mole of
this two moles of this and it's to form
one mole of methane you're going to
release 74 kilojoules of heat so this is
a stable reaction now there's a couple
of interesting things here and we'll
keep using this table over the next few
videos
you see here monoatomic oxygen
has a positive
standard heat of formation which means
it takes energy to form it right that if
you have a reaction
let me just say the reaction i'll write
it this way one half
of molecular oxygen as a gas
to go to
to go to one
to go to one mole of oxygen just as a
kind of in its gaseous state this tells
us
this tells us that this state has more
potential than this state and in order
for this reaction to occur you have to
add energy to it you have to put the
energy on the other side so it has to be
you would put a plus
so right here you would have to say plus
joules so you might say hey sal that
doesn't make sense oxygen is just oxygen
why why is there a heat of formation of
oxygen and that's because you always use
the elemental form as your reference
point so oxygen if you just look you
know if you just had a bunch of oxygen
sitting around it's going to be it's in
in the o2 form if you have a bunch of
hydrogen it's going to be h2 if you have
a bunch of nitrogen it's going to be n2
carbon on the other hand is just c and
it tends to be in its solid form
as graphite so
all heats of formation are relative to
the form that you find that element when
you have pure version of it not
necessarily its atomic form although
sometimes it is its atomic form now in
the next video we're going to use this
table which is a very handy table i cut
and pasted parts of it to actually solve
problems in in this last video i gave
you the heat of formation and we just
thought about a little bit in the next
few videos we're going to use this table
that gives us standard heats of
formation to actually figure out whether
reactions are endothermic meaning they
absorb energy or exothermic meaning
their release energy and we'll figure
out how much